for our first cancellation of the new
year we head up to beautiful Lake
Washington near the city of Seattle now
just to be clear I use the word
beautiful to describe specifically the
physical Topography of the area just
don't look over to your side or over
your shoulder because if you do
depending on where you happen to be
standing along the shore you might find
yourself staring at a collection of very
naked
people hi stranger now of course you
stand the risk of getting an eye full of
naked flab if you travel anywhere in the
Pacific Northwest but Washington the
risk is even greater because it is is
the site of something called Denny
Blaine Park which is we are informed a
beloved nudest Beach popular with the
LGBT community in the area Round Up The
Usual Suspects in fact this nudest beach
is so popular and so beloved that the
LGBT community recently came together no
pun intended to protest what they
perceived as a mortal threat to this
hangout spot no pun intended and the
threat came in the form of a playground
few months ago it was announced that
Seattle Parks and wre with the
assistance of a sizable donation from a
private donor plan to build a playground
nearby and this is a problem for the
exhibitionist gays over at Denny Blaine
because although it's legal for them to
gavant around naked almost anywhere in
the city or state they still aren't
allowed to get naked in front of
children so they protested the
playground they organized they got a
petition together got nearly 10,000
signatures on the petition they were
absolutely incensed that the city
considered prioritizing the needs of
children over the desires of
self-described weirdos local news had
more on the controversy listen I'm in Dy
blae Park hundreds of people showed up
at that meeting tonight because they say
this place is a safe space and putting a
playground here would forever change
that as expected you guys can sign up
here where there in there as well the
proposal to put a playground at Denny
bla Park brought out a lot of people all
of them with their own story about the
park and why they're against the
proposal we can just be ourselves where
we can feel safe where we can feel heard
where we can see one another this is a
place where people come up and they ask
is it safe here am I accept it here and
every time I've smiled and said yes
Denny blae is a noted lgbtq plus safe
space it's been that way for decades
under Washington law it's not illegal to
be naked in public however it becomes
illegal if kids are nearby that's what
this playground would do want to
preserve our spaces the people who
showed up here believe the private
Anonymous donor who's willing to front
$550,000 for a playground wants to take
that space away from them they say that
it's not an intention to displace queer
communities or any specific community
and that may be true on the park side
but I'd love to ask the anonymous donor
whether that is
true there's also concern that someone
with money to burn can make such a big
change to a public park said we're
letting people with a fair amount of
money do an anonymous notation clearly
choosing how they want to see our car I
asked Andy Sheffer with Seattle Parks
and W about that Anonymous donor his
response well I can't really talk about
it a whole lot cuz it's Anonymous but he
did talk about how moving the public
comments were God you heard those
stories you know if more people could
hear these stories it's much bigger than
this part yes the stories the incredible
Stories the inspirational heartwarming
stories about gay people exposing their
genitals to strangers I mean if only
more people couldn't hear how important
it is to gay people that they be allowed
to expose their genitals to
strangers indeed LGBT people who aren't
able to take their pants off anywhere
and everywhere they want all the time
without restriction are are truly the
most
downtrodden Among Us forget starving
people in Africa forget children dying
of cancer forget everyone and focus
instead on LGBT people always give them
everything they want always all the time
no matter what it is because if you
don't then you are killing them you are
literally killing them that's the
message you heard it from the gay
activists themselves they said they want
to be themselves feel safe be heard now
you might point out that you know gay
people can be themselves and feel safe
and be heard everywhere in the country
but I think a more a more pressing
question is is why being yourself and
feeling safe and being heard must always
involve getting naked I think we should
get
naked what it doesn't work that way for
any other group of people have you
noticed that okay if you take any other
group and you say well here's a safe
space for you they're not going to
immediately strip off their clothes
that's only how it works with LGBT safe
spaces let me ask you something what if
there was someone out there who kept a
log of every single thing you did every
minute of the day I think that'd be
pretty creepy well what if I told you
it's exactly what happens every time you
go online your internet service provider
is allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited and can
legally sell this data to anyone that's
why I always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you do online many of you might be
wondering well if I'm routing all my
data through a VPN then doesn't that
mean that the VPN can see what I'm doing
and log my data instead and you're right
to think that many vpns claim to have a
no logs policy but have been caught
logging customer activity anyway Express
VPN is the only VPN I trust because they
are use a trusted server technology this
makes it impossible for their VPN
servers to store any data including logs
of any expressvpn customer and you don't
have to take my or expressvpn's word for
it expressvpn is so confident in their
are no logs claim even had one of the
biggest Assurance firms PwC audit their
technology so stop letting people keep
logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com Walsh YT and get three
extra months free that's exp rsvpn
docomo expressvpn.com Walt to learn more
but we haven't gotten to the best part
of that local Seattle news report um I
want you to listen to what this reporter
mentions very briefly at the end listen
no one at the meeting spoke for the
playground at this park I have put in a
public information request for the name
of the anonymous owner and something
else to note many people brought up a
drowning risk they say there's no
lifeguards at this beach and if you put
a playground here kids will be here
upping the chance they could drown as a
brief aside as a minor additional detail
we're told that if they build the
playground at this location children
might drown now the drowning risk thing
is probably mostly contrived playgrounds
are built next to Lakes all the time I
take my kids to playgrounds near Lakes
all the time it's like it's not an issue
because you know most people are not
dropping their 5-year-old off off at the
playground and then coming back to pick
them up before Sundown generally the
children are watched by adults and
adults can keep them from wandering down
to the water unsupervised but be that as
it me if you're actually worried that
the playground presents a significant
drowning risk to Children how is that
not your top concern how is that not the
headline I mean these people claim that
a playground at that location May well
lead to children dying and yet that is
somehow not their key objection their
key objection is that the children will
interfere with their ability to be naked
in public you got to be kidding so their
list of priorities has getting naked in
public at the top and preventing
children from drowning somewhere down
below that these people are so
unbelievably selfish that they can't
even pretend to care about anything more
than satisfying their own sexual desires
I mean it's the only thing they care
about in this world period And yet
prepare yourself for The Not So twist
ending here the LGBT protesters
prevailed no
and Seattle ultimately decided to reject
the $500,000 donation and scrap the
plans for the playground at that
location on one hand you had families
who wanted a place to take their
children to the park and on the other
you had selfish degenerates and by the
way when I call them degenerates I'm
only respecting their own preferred
adjective and oped in the local Seattle
publication The Stranger addressing this
controversy a few weeks ago had this
headline quote keep Denny Blaine de
generate I've gone to this park for
years and as a child of a queer person
who has lived in Seattle since the 80s I
know how critical it is for us to
maintain spaces where queer people don't
need to worry about Optics every damn
second in a world that's constantly
repressing our identities is it not
possible for queer people to have one
space really hoping the parks department
chooses another site because I don't
know where else I can go and feel
comfortable in my body in this damn City
yes where else in Seattle can a gay
person go well there's nowhere else for
them in Seattle life could be a dream
could be a
[Music]
dream it's a funny thing you know most
of us walk around in public every day
feeling comfortable in our bodies the
whole time and yet we never feel the
need to strip our clothes off and expose
ourselves to strangers but for this
self-described degenerate and his
friends the only way that he can feel
comfortable in his body is if his body
is on Full display for the world to see
their sexual desires come before
everything and everyone all the time and
that's how the gay nudus at Denny Blaine
Park got their way and it's also why
they are today
cancelled you've ever seen are in
Seattle and the hills the greenest Green
[Music]
in